lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
encontrar la derivada con respecto a x
de x cuadrada por el seno de x esto
elevado al cubo y lo que es interesante
es que hay muchas formas de llegar a la
respuesta así que te encargo que pausa
el vídeo y vea si puede resolverla por
tu cuenta
hay varias formas de resolver está
derivada una de ellas es aplicando
primero la regla de la cadena así que
déjame poner la regla de la cadena es
decir tomar es la derivada con respecto
a x de algo elevado al cubo
entonces así tomo la derivada vamos a
tener la derivada con respecto a ese
algo que es tres veces ese algo al
cuadrado por la derivada con respecto a
x de ese algo donde en este caso ese
algo es x cuadrado por el seno de x x
cuadrado por el seno de x ok esto es
simplemente aplicar la regla de la
cadena ahora la segunda parte a que va a
ser igual y lo voy a poner con color
rojo esta derivada bueno para derivar
esta segunda parte puedo aplicar la
regla del producto tengo el producto de
dos expresiones entonces voy a aplicar
la regla del producto
déjame notarlo la regla del producto
entonces tomaré la derivada de la
primera
la derivada de x cuadrada es 2x por la
segunda expresión seno de x más la
primera expresión tal cual es
x cuadrada por la derivada de la segunda
expresión la derivada del seno de x es
el coseno de x esta es la regla del
producto aplicada a esta parte de rojo y
todo esto por supuesto esta x esta
primera expresión así que déjame
reescribirlo 3 x y aquí tengo el
producto de dos cosas elevado la segunda
potencia eso es lo mismo que los
productos elevados a la segunda potencia
y después multiplicarlos por lo tanto 3
x x cuadrada al cuadrado es ex a la
cuarta por el seno cuadrado de x y todo
esto multiplicando al logo de rojo y
bueno algebraica mente podemos
simplificar si distribuimos este 3 x x
cuarta por el seno de que es cuadrada
multiplicando por cada uno de los dos
suman dos entonces tengo
x cuarta por aquí 2 x bueno esos 6 x a
la quinta y luego seno cuadrado de x por
el seno de x eso es lo mismo que seno
cúbico de x y luego veamos tengo tres
que multiplican a x cuarta por x
cuadrada eso es lo mismo que x sexta
entonces me quedan 3 x sexta seno
cuadrado de x por coseno de x y aquí lo
tienes esta es una estrategia para
resolver esta derivada usando primero la
regla de la cadena y después la regla
del producto pero también hay otra forma
de resolver la pausa el vídeo y piensa
en qué otra forma puedes resolver esta
misma derivada bueno la otra forma de
resolverlo es usando algebraica mentem
las propiedades de los exponentes en
cuyo caso esto va a ser igual si primero
elevamos al cubo me queda la derivada
con respecto a x y tengo x cuadrada por
seno de x esto al cubo bueno es lo mismo
que x cuadrada al cubo eso se excede a
sexta
y luego seno de x elevado al cubo lo
cual es seno cúbico de x lo único que
hice fue usar las mismas propiedades de
los exponentes que aquí usamos para
elevar al cuadrado
si tengo el producto de dos cosas
elevadas a la tercera potencia eso es lo
mismo que los productos elevados a la
tercera potencia y después multiplicar
los y ahora como a está costes derivada
bueno por aquí lo primero que voy a
hacer es usar la regla del producto
hagámoslo la regla del producto así que
tomó la derivada de la primera expresión
y me queda la derivada de x a la sexta
es 6x a la quinta y esto lo multiplicó
por el segundo tal cual por el seno
cúbico de x bien ya esto les sumó el
primero tal cual esta x la sexta por la
derivada del segundo por la derivada con
respecto a x del seno cúbico de x
ahora para abordar esta segunda derivada
lo que vamos a hacer es de hecho la
regla de la cadena la regla de la cadena
y cuál es esta derivada bueno tenemos
algo elevado al cubo entonces la
derivada me va a quedar tres veces ese
algo al cuadrado por la derivada de ese
álbum en este caso ese álbum es el seno
de x y su derivada es el coseno de x y
no olvidemos todo lo demás tengo 6x
quintana por el seno cúbico de x mas x
elevado a la sexta potencia por lo que
acabamos de obtener y ahora si
simplificamos esto vamos a ver que en
efecto llegamos al resultado que antes
teníamos es decir que estos dos
resultados van a ser equivalentes
observa estas dos cosas de amarillo son
iguales y ahora esto que sobran es lo
mismo que multiplicar x a la sexta por
tres por el seno cuadrado de x por el
coseno de x
muy bien y bueno una cosa agradable de
pensar sobre las matemáticas es que si
hacemos las cosas de dos formas
distintas pero siguiendo razonamientos
lógicos llegamos al mismo punto pero el
punto aquí es que existen múltiples
estrategias para llegar al resultado
correcto tal vez primero existe la regla
de la cadena y después la regla del
producto o tal vez existe primero la
regla del producto y después la regla de
la cadena y tal vez en este caso podrías
debatir cuál de ellas es más rápida am
que en esta ocasión parece ser la
segunda por poquito pero a veces la
forma de desarrollarlas es muy similar
si una es más clara que otra entonces
este es el camino preferible o tal vez
que tras reducir la cantidad de
explicaciones complicadas o la cantidad
de pasos para así reducir la cantidad de
errores que puedes cometer bueno nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo